Stannis Baratheon: Nobody knows why the Targaryens
first came to the island of Dragonstone.
Old Valyria was at the height of its power
and the center of the civilized world, which
ended at the Narrow Sea.
Westeros was a filthy backwater with seven
kings squabbling over borders and minor glories.
So much for progress.
The island itself was and is nothing!
It had no gold or gems to lure Valyrian nobility.
All it has is rock.
Mostly a shiny black stone too brittle for
war and too sharp for building.
The Targaryens called it Dragonglass.
I call it useless.
But the Targaryens managed to build a castle
here.
Simpletons claim that they used ancient Valyrian
sorcery, forgetting that the Targaryens brought
a small army with them from Essos.
There is no magic in strong backs, though
admittedly, the castle is unlike any in Westeros,
foreign and strange.
If the Targaryens ever regretted their barren
outpost and longed for the comforts of home,
the Doom made their folly permanent.
Valyria collapsed into the waves and was no
more.
To look east was to see the ruin of their
homeland, the greatest civilization before
or since; but to look west, as Aegon realized,
was to see a fertile land, ripe for conquest.
Perhaps a new Valyria.
Though good for little else, Dragonstone proved
the perfect staging point for Aegon's invasion
of Westeros.
The Blackwater Bay granted easy access to
the continent.
The lands there were disputed by three kingdoms:
The Reach, the Iron Islands, and the Stormlands.
But their capitals were far enough away that
none of them could mount a force before Aegon
got a foothold.
Even if their kings had been able to stop
bickering over whose problem it was.
Then it was too late, Aegon had chosen his
first camp well.
With the bay to the east, the river to the
south and open fields to the north and west,
his army was impossible to take by surprise.
A perfect site for an invasion and, one day,
his capital city, King's Landing.
Brynden Tully: Aegon Targaryen landed to our
south and, as had many before him, liked the
look of the Riverlands.
My ancestor Edmyn Tully led the desertion
of Riverlords to his cause and was rewarded
by getting to watch King Harren burn in his
own tower.
Catelyn Stark: On the shores of the Gods Eye
due north of the Isle of Faces rises a monument
of arrogance and cruelty.
Harrenhal.
For a people who prided themselves on their
ships, the Ironmen of old seized any chance
to leave them and carved out a vast kingdom
from the peaceful Riverlords.
Their empire reached its zenith under King
Harren Hoare, called "the Black" by those
he terrorized and by his own men, though they
meant it proudly.
King Harren enslaved the Riverlands to raise
the mightiest fortress Westeros had ever seen;
a castle that could garrison a million men,
with walls so vast that winters would come
and go and besieging armies grow old and grey
before the castle fell.
Five towers he ordered, reaching into the
heavens like grasping fingers, a monstrosity
which he forced our people to build for their
own subjugation.
But the very day the slaves laid the last
stone, Aegon Targaryen and his sisters arrived
in the south.
When they arrived with their small army, Harren
laughed and shut the gates.
Harrenhal would have its first test and an
easy one at that.
It failed.
Harrenhal could have survived all the armies
in Westeros combined, but Harren learned that
the tallest and thickest walls meant little
to dragons, for dragons fly.
Brynden Tully: The problem with huge castles
is they blind you to what's outside, both
by their size and the arrogance they inspire.
Not that the ironborn ever lacked for that.
They take pride in their ignorance of every
trapping of civilization.
Though any baker could have told them that
fire turns stone walls into an oven.
And so Harren the Black finally lived up to
his name, and the Riverlords swept the ironborn
back to the sea.
Samwell Tarly: When Aegon the Conqueror came
to the Iron Islands, the Priest King Lodos
claimed his divine father, the ironborn's
Drowned God, had shown him krakens pulling
Aegon's ships into the deep.
No krakens ever arrived, and even if they
had, wouldn't have stopped Aegon and his dragons
without wings of their own.
Confused, Lodos filled his pockets with stones
and walked into the sea to "take counsel with
his father."
Thousands followed him, but apparently, the
Drowned God didn't appreciate a crowd.
Their corpses washed up on the Iron Islands
for years.
Randyll Tarly: When Aegon Targaryen declared
that Westeros was now his, King Mern IX allied
with King Loren Lannister of the Westerlands.
Together, they fought to save Westeros from
another foreign barbarian whose family practices
put decent men to shame.
But the dragons won.
The Field of Fire claimed Mern and all his
sons, grandsons, and brothers.
Instead of using the castle for what it was
built to do, Harlen Tyrell surrendered it
to Aegon without a fight.
In exchange, Harlen was given the castle his
family had served for thousands of years with
all its attendant lands and lords.
Margaery Tyrell: For over a thousand years,
the Greenhand's sons and grandsons ruled The
Reach as House Gardener.
The offshoots of his daughters grew into vast
and powerful houses in their own right.
Except for House Tyrell.
We chose instead to serve our Gardener cousins
faithfully as stewards.
To manage their stronghold of Highgarden and
the daily affairs of the Reach.
Our words are "Growing Strong."
And under our stewardship, the Reach did just
that.
As did we.
Until a blundering king almost cost us everything.
Aegon Targaryen had landed in Westeros.
King Mern allied us with the Rock to repel
the upstart's army.
One can only marvel that King Mern did not
reconsider when he saw the living dragons
against him.
Perhaps he should have sought counsel from
his trusted stewards before he set out.
Then again, perhaps he did.
At the Field of Fire, Aegon, and let us not
forget his sisters, burned the combined armies
of the Reach and Rock.
King Mern paid for his misjudgment with his
life and that of his ancient family.
In a day, the Reach had lost its king, its
ruling house, and most of its army.
Thankfully for everyone, my ancestor, Harlen
Tyrell, had better sense.
Until the maesters sorted out the entail among
Mern's cousins, Harlen, the steward was acting
lord of Highgarden.
To ensure peace and life in the Reach, he
would yield the castle of Aegon.
The other castles and families would then
follow, as they had since the Dawn Age.
Aegon had a continent to conquer, and the
fertile Reach was too valuable to raze.
He accepted Harlen's proposal and welcomed
our lands into his kingdom.
To show his gratitude, Aegon entitled Harlen
to Highgarden, the castle his family had served
for a thousand years, and made House Tyrell
his Wardens of the South, choosing us over
older, greater families in the Reach.
Our House thus owed everything to the Targaryens.
Tywin Lannister: The Lannisters reigned as
Kings of the Rock for thousands of years and
worked to make it the envy of the rest of
the Seven Kingdoms.
Our time as kings ended, however, when Aegon
Targaryen, otherwise known as Aegon the Conqueror,
arrived in Westeros with his army.
The last King of the Rock, King Loren Lannister,
joined forces with King Mern Gardener, the
King of the Reach.
Together, with sixty thousand men, they met
the Targaryen host in open battle.
History tells us that Aegon unleashed all
three of his dragons, slaughtering four thousand
men at what came to be known as "the Field
of Fire."
King Mern himself was burned alive that day,
and House Gardener turned to ash with him.
Seeing both the threat and opportunity the
Targaryens represented, Loren wisely surrendered
and aided Aegon in his further conquest of
Westeros.
The Lannisters were thus appointed Lords Paramount
of the Westerlands and Wardens of the West,
titles we hold to this day.
Brienne of Tarth: While Aegon burned the kings
of the Iron Islands, the Rock and the Reach,
his fiercest commander and rumored brother,
Orys Baratheon, set out to subdue the Stormlands.
No matter how fierce a warrior he was, no
one could have envied his task.
Storm's End had seen thousands of years of
war and never fallen, but Argilac, the Storm
King, chose not to barricade himself behind
its walls and gave Orys the battle he must
have hoped for.
Orys slew Argilac and took Argilac's castle,
kingdom, daughter, sigil, and House words.
House Baratheon became the Lord of the Stormlands.
Jon Snow: When Aegon and his dragons landed
on Westeros, the Kings of the Rock and the
Reach sent all of their men to die to defend
their grounds.
Torrhen Stark knelt to spare his people the
same fate.
He placed duty above pride.
Sansa Stark: The south had already fallen
to Aegon and his dragons.
Only the North remained.
My ancestor, King Torrhen Stark, marched the
North down to the Trident and beheld Aegon's
army, larger than Torrhen's own by half and
with three dragons circling overhead.
Many northern bannermen wanted to attack anyway,
claiming northern valor would carry the day.
Others wanted to fall back to Moat Cailin
and make a stand there.
But Torrhen had heard how the armies of the
Rock and the Reach had burned on the Field
of Fire and had seen the fires still glowing
beneath the rubble of Harrenhal.
He knelt and laid his ancient crown as Aegon's
feet and rose a king no more but Lord of Winterfell
and Warden of the North.
Some Northerners still sneer at my ancestor
as "The King Who Knelt," forgetting that because
of Torrhen, they're alive today to sneer.
Their ancestors didn't leave their burned
bones at the Trident, and their twisted swords
didn't fill Aegon's new throne.
Petyr Baelish: No army in the Seven Kingdoms
can match the pride and chivalry of the Knights
of the Vale.
After all, they were the first true knights
in Westeros.
Until the dragons changed the game.
When Aegon the Conqueror landed in Westeros,
the Queen Regent of the Vale shut the Bloody
Gate against the Targaryens and massed the
Knights of the Vale behind it to lock it.
But Visenya simply flew her dragon to a balcony
of the Eyrie, where the boy king was playing
and gave the boy a ride around the castle
in return for his mother's submission.
The High Sparrow: When Aegon the Conqueror
landed in Westeros, the High Septon locked
himself in a sept for seven days and seven
nights.
Finally, the Crone lifted her golden lamp
and showed him the path ahead.
The High Septon, himself, would anoint and
crown Aegon as Lord of the Seven Kingdoms;
and the Faith Militant rallied behind Aegon
in governing his newly united land.
Yet Aegon and his sisters never wholly accepted
the Faith.
The High Septon had conceded Aegon's marriages
to his sisters as a relic of his Valyrian
heritage, which would soon fade.
Ellaria Sand: Aegon Targaryen sought to unite
Westeros, as Nymeria had Dorne.
The other six kingdoms fell quickly before
his dragons and ambition.
When his sister-wife, Rhaenys, flew her dragon
south and demanded Dorne's surrender as well,
Princess Meria Martell warned, "I will not
fight you, nor will I kneel to you.
Dorne has no king.
Tell your brother that."
Rhaenys threatened that the next time the
Targaryens would come with fire and blood.
Meria replied, "You may burn us, my lady,
but you will not bend us, break us or make
us bow.
This is Dorne; you are not wanted here.
Return at your peril!"
Rhaenys did, and she died.
Her dragon died.
All her soldiers died.
Eventually, her brother, the Conqueror, conceded
that what Nymeria had done, he could not undo.
Generations later, another foolish Targaryen
invaded Dorne.
He died as well.
Eventually, we did join the Seven Kingdoms,
but when we wanted and on our terms.